so there were times when we had to make
those cuts and there were a couple of
headcount reductions earlier on in after
my arrival schering-plough one was a
voluntary early retirement program
followed by a reduction in force program
and some painful decisions had to be
taken at that time it was quite
understandable to the rest of the
colleagues in the company that these
these reductions made sense because the
company was bleeding cash and losing
sales later on we had another challenge
in a company and we had to reduce costs
further and at that time to when the
action was announced the logic was
pretty clear to the people that that was
the right time it is very important that
we then in any company when certain
painful decisions around headcount
reductions are made that they be made as
early as possible and with as much
explanation as possible and then and
then one has to go beyond it and when
the reductions are actually made they
should be done as fairly as possible so
that those colleagues who are exited
there's a good sense among the ones who
remain why certain decisions had to be
taken
I know that in the case of sharing when
I first came and certain exits occurred
a lot of the exits among senior
management had to do with the
willingness of people to adopt a more
flexible mindset because this company
was going to go down a transformation
road and those that would have
difficulty accepting that concept
probably should go somewhere else so
that became a factor in the discussion
at that point when one does a reduction
in headcount under cyclical
circumstances or unexpected
circumstances then in many cases whole
departments get shut down or whole sales
divisions get restructured in which case
you might have different groups of
people leaving the company quite
different from the the people who might
leave the company when a CEO just
arrives in a new situation
now the hiring decision is very
important and nobody has a perfect
batting average but it won't one can bat
higher then of course the productivity
goes up dramatically when I look at
people I do look at a few basics first
the first thing I always look for is the
attitude you can always train people on
skills you can give people special
courses but you can't give special
courses an attitude that's something
that comes from from from within if
people have a positive outlook to life
if people are anxious to work in a team
environment if people are anxious I want
to see the colleagues around them
succeed those are people with the
attitude that will do better than those
that are too self-oriented and that
starts to become pretty obvious after
you've asked a few questions whether a
person is more an outside individual or
a self individual the other thing you
look for is the fire in the belly is
there a passion is there a desire to
learn is there a desire to grow is there
a curiosity that that's going to get
people to new places again it's an
instinctive assessment that you make
after you've seen a lot of people and
finally you look for people who will
have the ability to learn absorb and
drove sometimes people may not become
competent in their own areas and that
probably will then not allow them to be
very good if you're trying to hire a
good research scientist in
pharmaceuticals and they don't seem to
have the ability to be a strong research
scientist then they may have the right
attitude and the fire in the belly but
they're not going to be very successful
in that job so but but I do i do place a
very high level of weight